excuse me while I use my dog for white
balancing good morning Hank it's
Thursday special surprise bonus video so
Hank for the first time since 2012 we
are going on tour to celebrate the
release of Turtles all the way down and
also because we need an excuse to spend
a few weeks together there will be music
and laughter and joy and I'll probably
cry because I cry a lot cues will be aid
surprises will be plentiful and news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon will be
shared so today I thought I'd answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
about the tour beginning with where are
you going okay there are 19 stops and
I'm gonna do this all in one take New
York Washington DC Charlotte North
Carolina Asheville North Carolina
Atlanta Georgia Orlando Florida where we
will be playing Hanks High School
Auditorium
Nashville Tennessee Cincinnati Ohio my
hometown of Indianapolis Indiana st.
Louis Missouri Chicago Illinois
Minneapolis and then on to Hanks
hometown of Missoula Montana from there
to Spokane Washington and then
Bellingham Washington and then Portland
Oregon and then two shows in the San
Francisco Bay Area and then down to Los
Angeles and I did it who says that I'm
over reliant on jump cuts
one other thing sadly there will be no
Hank that the show's in Asheville and
Atlanta but there will be special
surprise guest tanks playing the role of
Hank and you will hardly know the
difference so if you if you might
remember that in 2012 we did not visit
the Midwest and there was much
consternation and I said at the time so
Midwest this is me hugging you saying
I'm sorry
we'll be there next time you will note
that just six short years later I am
keeping that promise and this time I
must say to the people of Texas and the
American Southwest and also the people
living in the vast nation of not America
I'm sorry and we will try to visit you
soon why no love for insert location
here I love insert location here I've
always loved insert location here insert
personal anecdote about insert location
here to prove love for insert location
here and then express regret are these
shows gonna be spoiler free yes when it
comes to my books but there might be
some Star Wars spoilers is it weird if I
come alone no lots of people will be
coming alone in fact there will be a
special letter in the program just for
people coming alone but also you might
find that you can make friends over at
the two otário discord or maybe even at
the show how much for the tickets so
ticket prices have been set by the
bookstores hosting the event so that
they don't lose money so it depends on
the city and the venue but
every ticket comes with a signed copy of
turtles all the way down and also some
other goodies will there be a book
signing right so this is the bad news
partly because of the size of the
venue's but mostly because of my brains
malfunctioning there will not be a
signing after the show I'm really sorry
about this and it's something that I've
struggled with a lot but yeah it's just
something I have to do so I'm sorry will
you guys be singing together yeah I'm
also sorry about this the answer is
probably yes but only briefly are you
bringing Turtles only metaphorical ones
but we're bringing a lot of those like
an infinite set of them there is
anything to do with you below where you
can get more info about each event and
also tickets I will try to be in
comments answering your questions I hope
to see lots of you on tour it's gonna be
an awesome time and Hank I cannot wait
to traverse the country with you I will
see you on Friday